just erupts like a [ __ ] bomb so you
always have a fight
so all right well i'll tell you the one
in santa barbara then
um that's like let me think the funny
thing is there are so many fight stories
there's a label for it i'll tell you
this
santa barbara one santa barbara two i
have five stories too but it looks
like me getting beat up so i don't tell
those stories very much
all right you're next yeah so yeah i got
some
stuck in the mouth that i woke up the
next day next story yeah so this fight
um at the time i was like eight nineteen
eighteen is illegal highly legal illegal
um but i wasn't in santa barbara i was
going to visit a friend in santa barbara
for halloween right um and because
halloween in uc santa barbara is [ __ ]
crazy people are like there from
everywhere it's just like an insane
it's like crazy how [ __ ] many people
are there and getting drunk and whatever
so we go to visit my buddy right and as
we're driving up there
it's like me and like five of my friends
and a carload of my other friends was up
there the night before but they were
coming back and they called us and
they're like holy [ __ ] dude like last
night we got in this huge fight with
like [ __ ]
these guys like it was [ __ ] crazy i
threw somebody out of a window
and we're like holy [ __ ] like that's
crazy like they're telling us the story
and we're like that's insane dude holy
[ __ ] and they're like we're laughing
and they they go on this epic journey
we're like whatever okay cool so we get
there
and we're at the party right there's
people in the [ __ ] kitchen
and uh i see a guy that i had issues
with before
what was the issue right it was uh some
girl [ __ ] like where
was it always girls
i was dating a girl and this guy was
like trying to talk to the girl
and i was young i was stupid i was like
mad about it i should have just
if now in retrospect it should have been
like who gives a [ __ ] about this whole
situation i'm gonna have a good time you
were [ __ ] eighteen or nine i was
eighteen
yeah i was like i was like a dumb ass
kid and it was quick but anyways i
didn't like the dude and i was like
[ __ ] that guy i was like i don't like
him what's his name
i'm not gonna say his name but anyway so
i i like saw him and i was like all
right but you know what like [ __ ] this
dude like i'm gonna get down with this
dude like it's like we don't like each
other we're standing in this
like room what the [ __ ] are we doing you
know like he sees me i see him we're
gonna act like
there's not not a problem so i tell him
like hey let's go outside
jesus so we step outside and he's like
uh he was bigger he was taller than me
he's like oh so you want to fight me but
why and i just [ __ ] hit him dude i
hit him like boom like in the cheeks
i just was so dope about pat dude he
never allows the situation to be
assessed
same thing with the guy that came to
your doorstep he could have came to
apologize
but you already warned him you know you
told him if you come to my house i'm
going to knock you out
and in his mind he took that as i'm
going to go to his house and apologize
he did warn him so me and like so but
there was like history there like we
knew we didn't like each other so
anyways i hit this dude and we like
start scuffling right and like we like
he like tackles me through a beer pong
table like we're flipping and [ __ ] damn
and so so uh my buddy that same guy dee
who's like cool as [ __ ] but he's crazy
like him and my other homie uh are
holding like all the people back there
are trying to break it up
and at first they're and it's all our
friends we all know each other and uh
and like dee gets mad to the point like
he's trying to stop him and then he just
gets mad and he turns around he's like
the next [ __ ] steps forward i'm
a [ __ ]
and everyone was like oh [ __ ] right and
they just kind of stopped so me and this
guy keeps scuffling but then he like
gets away
he gets away and like he goes into the
crowd and then people broke it up
and then i was like okay like if that
was the end of that fight right we like
calm down
they leave they're like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i'ma [ __ ] your ass up
later like he's talking to [ __ ] or
whatever blah blah
and so we go back in the house and we're
like all right [ __ ] like we're chilling
we're drinking
and like my my buddy d that guy who's
nuts comes up to me he's like i [ __ ]
love you man that was so sick like he's
like so
i'm like i was like that was stupid
[ __ ] whatever right so we're just
drinking like having fun
so now we're there the party's broken up
but we're there
and my buddy's neighbors are there now
it's halloween so we
we weren't dressed up like i didn't go
in the costume or whatever but that
his neighbors were dressed up as the
village people so it's like a native
american like a construction worker
[ __ ]
biker this stuffed biker and [ __ ] for
some reason some white dude that was
dressed up as easy like
in the group too
yeah yeah so we're there and then uh
we're just chilling and then
we i hear this guy like he goes he looks
at us he's like those guys are [ __ ]
gay like he points at us he's like those
guys are [ __ ] gay
right and i was kind of like i heard it
and i was like what like i was like
whatever maybe he wasn't talking about
us and then i hear him again he's like
nah those guys are [ __ ] they're gay
like these dudes are gays but
and i turn i was like what the [ __ ] did
you say excuse me that's a
yeah it's [ __ ] maybelline [ __ ] yeah
yeah
so this dude calls us gay and i'm like i
confronted him what the [ __ ] like what's
like what why are you like what's going
on yeah and he's like oh no it's just a
joke dude it's just a joke like it's
just a joke oh my god that's
kind of like what kind of joke is just
you calling us
that line is the most that's the line
that always gets into an actual fight
you can't do that you can say it's just
a joke
i'm sick and tired of getting people
saying that like that's not an excuse
yeah that is not an excuse it was just a
joke no no no that's that's not that's
not how that was just like
like if it wasn't a joke form maybe i
could understand it but it's like
literally he was just like hey these
guys are gay
that's the punchlining points that you
yeah you're gay
you're talking to me why would you think
that maybe the finger that's two inches
away from my face
that that's when you turn your back and
start talking that's like yeah when you
turn back you're like
so these so like [ __ ] starts kind of
getting heated between me
and the construction worker it's the
construction worker that called us get
out of the village people
yeah yeah so like shit's starting to
we're starting to beef or whatever like
we're shit's starting to get heated and
i remember i told him i was like go [ __ ]
yourself i told him that and i
it like i i people that say words don't
have power they do because i saw this
visually like made him really upset
[ __ ] his whole demeanor up and it made
me laugh and started laughing because
he's [ __ ] hilarious like he's very
upset as you tell me about that
he's like hold on a [ __ ] what
did you say to me and shit's getting
heated like she's getting crazy heated
and easy
comes in the middle right he's he's like
the ring leader and he's like everybody
[ __ ] stop
we live here we're the neighbors we
don't know who the [ __ ] you are blah
blah you guys gotta get the [ __ ] out
right
and everyone's like looking at him and
again my buddy d looks at me
he's like i'ma suck this dude
this guy's wearing blackface i'm gonna
knock him out and then i did i was just
like
all right and so easy he's standing in
the middle of the circle
and he's talking and my buddy just
[ __ ] boom hits him and his head like
you know sometimes dudes get hit and
their head just like it looks like a
bobble head yeah he just walks
when he gets like that it was like he
was knocked out he got hit he didn't get
knocked out but he got cracked and
when he got cracked like everyone like
my buddies we like shoved them all out
so like somehow because we were in the
doorway like we shoved them all out
door closes so it was like chaos chaos
door closed and it was like calm
and we're like okay what's gonna happen
and then they [ __ ] barge back in like
like all of them like a wave and easy
like jumps in the middle and he's like
who the [ __ ] hit me in the face right
and then
it was quiet for like two beats like
dude we're all just kind of looking at
him
and my buddy d just
hit went again dude boom same punch like
bang
and then it was like a bomb like
everyone just started fighting boom
people were just swinging in the doorway
it was like the [ __ ] battle of
thermopylae like because it was all in
the doorway right
and like fools are like punching over
the shoulders
[Applause]
so [ __ ] we're all throwing down and
like the indian they were pretty big
so some guy i don't know who had this
power but some guy had the
the native american dude's face on the
wall like this and i just saw it and i
just
punched him but he saw the punch coming
but he couldn't move because someone was
just holding his way
so he was like so you don't know who was
holding his face i don't know someone
was holding
whoever wasn't strong as [ __ ] because
they had one like a death grip on his
face and he was just
drinking a beer somebody started
littering and they started crying
[Laughter]
that's enough
[ __ ] so uh
i hit him and then the construction
worker i saw him looking at like
one of the like he was trying to hit one
of my homies and i just rushed him boom
boom boom it's like one two so one two
one two one two and he just dropped into
the corner
and my buddy pulled me off and uh i so i
got
like he was done he was neutralized and
then the indian guy somehow
like so he my buddy jumps i see
the the same dude that from the last
story who's like i'm gonna kill you
[ __ ] like he's always just
getting dudes and rear naked chokes so
he jumps rear naked choke right
my other buddy d is surprisingly strong
doesn't realize my homies on his back
grabs the the native american dude
suplexes him with the other homie on his
back boom
knocks him down because my homie said he
was just on his back and all of a sudden
he was just upside down he's like i
don't know
why but my head was then in the kitchen
floor like boom
so he's getting choked out and then my
other buddy d
goes on is like a knee like a [ __ ]
knight like this and just start sucking
so this dude is getting like waterboard
torch cia tortured in this kitchen
uh somehow the fight stops like it just
it just ends like it just it's enough
like enough is enough
and then we leave we're like okay the
cops are coming we gotta go you know
like this is
all bad like my buddies we destroyed his
house his kitchen's [ __ ] ruined
there's kitchen
magnets all over the fridge magnets all
over the floor that [ __ ] was broken
he's like that he's like this is
unacceptable
and we leave and as we're leaving we
realize uh
because i didn't realize this until
after but that same group that my homies
had called me earlier about that got in
a fight they it was the same guys
oh cause we were leaving and i hear them
they were the neighbors
so they were just [ __ ] neighbors
because i just i just heard them go
two nights in the [ __ ] road man this
is [ __ ]
and i just was like oh it was them and
we just dipped out
and that was it one of those people they
were the village people i don't know if
they were the village people the night
before but my no because my buddy said
someone was dressed as pikachu
like that's right maybe we change our
outfits maybe we won't get a [ __ ] so
those dudes
i mean they're obviously we're starting
[ __ ] because they're like how are you
getting fight
two nights in a row yeah if you're if
you and the the luck bro of the other
guys that [ __ ] them up the other
homies that [ __ ] them up
that's what they get but i mean justice
because that's the thing about like that
college environment like especially
santa barbara there's so much young
people
getting [ __ ] up like about halloween
right yeah you have a lot of like nuts
young like like dudes that are like like
trying to be macho and [ __ ] like that
shit's all over the place but
yeah dude we [ __ ] up the village
people on easy man
funny and that was college college is
such a weird experience because well
riverside was a weird experience because
riverside is still very hood
you know what i mean so there was a
mingling of especially especially when
you were in college yeah so nice
students and then there's people who
actually live in riverside
that are [ __ ] thugs like thug thugs
cause i told the story on the podcast
before about title again but
when i was i never wanted to go to
riverside uh when i but the day before i
left riverside
my house got shot up because of some
poor decisions that i made but but after
that i decided